[Music]
okay everybody i
am so thrilled today because i am joined
by the lovely georgina campbell you know
her from broadchurch
krypton and my favorite episode of black
mirror hang the dj
how you doing today georgina i'm good
thank you how are you
i'm doing great so i'm really excited i
was fortunate enough to get a screener
to watch the film you are starring in
coming out this friday
wildcat and you play the badass
mysterious journalist cat
young so it's interesting this film for
just seeing
the role type of role you're playing in
it because it's
a tough role to pull off because you're
captive you're
chained to a bed uh and there's some
like gruesome
scenes here were you hesitating at all
taking on a role like this
um no i i read the script and i just
thought it was written so well and it
was so exciting
and the character goes through so much
so i was like really excited to be able
to take that on
um and yeah i mean we
we spoke about you know the the torture
and
um we tried to make it as you know it's
not too gratuitous
it's part of the story it has to be
there but it's kind of filmed in a way
that's
uh hopefully not gonna gross people out
yeah no 100 and it's exciting and
with that i think it adds to the huge
emotional moments your character has in
this film
and it goes to really dark places
for your character now your process as
an actress getting there was that
a dark place you stayed in like are you
method in your acting
process or what is that kind of like for
you doing such a like dark
part um i did lots of
research about people who have been
abducted in real life
and they've you know written books and
it was amazing so that kind of like
really
got me into the headspace of
understanding what it's like to be in
that scenario
um and also we were filming in l.a
and it was the first time i was filming
there and you know i didn't really know
anyone so it was quite isolating i was
kind of like living on my own in this
little flat in burbank
um so i think that added to the
atmosphere of it as well
but no i mean i wasn't in character the
whole time
okay thank god because when i see a role
like that i always feel like are they
miserable on set too like i feel bad for
the actor as well but
no that that's good to hear and
interesting too because you're
mentioning research for the role did you
also for your research
take any inspiration from other film
roles or tv
or parts that you've seen in movies or
just movies in general that kind of
inspired your portrayal of cat
um no i would say that mostly it was um
the the reading material really like i
read about mandalinto
and uh judith tebbett and um i watched a
really good documentary about james
foley
and uh that kind of really helped me and
then it was just
it was in the writing and you know you
you just
as soon as you're in that scenario as
well like even though obviously it's all
fake but you know i was
chained to this bed and i was with such
amazing actors it all just sort of comes
alive and you just you feel it
yeah no 100 you totally and the audience
feels it and that's just
a credit to your acting ability and it's
exciting for anyone like me who's a huge
fan of you and just watching your career
and how exciting it's been
what will you take the most from this
part in doing this film when you look
back at your career um it was just an
amazing opportunity to do a film i
haven't
done many films before this and being
able to get this kind of lead role
and it was really amazing experience
um i'm working with such fantastic
actors it was really incredible working
with nedo and i learned a lot from
watching him um
so it's just been great experience and
it's just made me want to do more movies
really
that's awesome and now i'm now i'm just
thinking where my head is going but you
just mentioned that you were chained to
the bed on set
now was that easy to just pull off or
did you have to keep calling someone
over like hey can you let me out of this
thing or would you actually sit
down i have to call someone they have to
let me out
yeah clunky um yes no one ever forgot
about you or anything that you were like
hanging over there
okay good um just making sure so
switching base a bit
just about georgina um how have you been
during this whole crazy year like what
do you kind of pass the time during all
this like what any passions or hobbies
you do
um i've been working actually really
luckily i've been on
i'm doing an apple tv series called
suspicion and we started
um at the beginning of last year and we
had we did have about um
five months six months off like
everybody did um and to be honest
there's a lot of
watching tv sitting on the sofa um
i like to do embroidery so that's i've
got okay
i've been doing um and i like reading as
well so
lots of reading oh that's that's great
and
you just mentioned too because i was
going to ask you about that the
suspicion show is there anything you can
tell us about it or
like what can we expect is it a thriller
is it a mystery
yeah it's a thriller it's a really
exciting
story actually it's you know about this
group of people
who are accused of kidnapping someone
and they have to prove their innocence
and they sort of end up going on the run
and are trying to figure out what
happened and how it happened it's hard
to talk about because there's lots of
spoilers
um but it's gonna be fantastic oh i
can't wait that's gonna be an apple you
said right
can't wait um so that's exciting and
then
what's interesting too is i always love
seeing what
any time an actress i'm a fan of or
actor posts about shows they like
i always take that as like a big
recommendation and i trust your taste
because i remember you had posted about
binging dark and loving dark on netflix
is there any other tv or movie you've
watched recently that you could suggest
to your fans because i think a lot of
people love hearing they're kind of like
heroes
what they like to watch yeah what have i
been watching recently
i watched the hbo um documentary about
woody allen which i thought was
fantastic oh
okay rock it's quite intense but i
thought it was brilliant so
i would definitely recommend that yeah
no that's a good uh warm-up for people
for wildcats so if you want to watch
really dark stuff you go back-to-back
boom there you go um now also
do you want to get more into
behind the scenes ever like writing or
directing i think you have a history of
writing a bit right
correct me um yeah no i i'm i'm actually
doing a master's at the moment in
screenwriting
um oh nice to do that yeah in the future
i definitely like to get into writing
i don't know about directing but um it
seems to be something that
you know if you've got a lot of
experience there's lots of actors that
are kind of moving into the directing
place i mean i love olivia wilde i think
she's done that so well so
i mean you never know yeah hell yeah
that's that's great and that's fun to
see
actors branching out to that that people
can kind of relate and trust their
process and be cool to see you direct
some stuff and write more stuff
um now i also had mentioned before that
my favorite black mirror episode is hang
the dj so
i have to ask you about that because do
you
feel like the amazement of like how one
how good that episode was but just
being in a big show like that and being
in just one episode
that touches a lot of people and sticks
with people do you like
i don't even know how to ask this
question because it's a weird question
but like are you aware of like
maybe that that that hangs around with
people like
did you feel like wow this is awesome
like i'm in this show and a lot of
people are talking about it and like
people are just fans of you just from
maybe that episode alone i could say
that's what got me into your career but
do you feel that at all on the other
side you know what i mean um
yeah i knew i know i mean i knew black
mirror was a big show it was already a
big show before
i got onto it and i was so excited i
really wanted to be in black mirror so i
really kind of like i've
auditioned for lots of different
episodes and really worked to get myself
on that show
and when we were filming it i don't
think we knew
how it would be received we we it was
because it was a lot different as well
in tone i guess a bit like san junipero
where it's sort of
different tone than the rest of the
series which is really dark um
but i just enjoyed the experience so
much i think we all did so i'm really
glad that um
that transcended to people watching it
and that they enjoyed watching it yeah
yeah no that's just good for me to hear
as a fan because like i i'm excited
because like
yeah i still think about that episode
and i think about your performance in it
i thought it was
just amazing um but
yeah and one more thing i have to ask
because
in research for this interview yesterday
i actually saw
an article and video speculating that
you might be the next doctor on doctor
who can you give
any truth to this rumor or is this all
just rumors
this is all just ringless okay
okay anything about doctor who um but i
it's a funny rumor
okay exciting all right because i
thought i struck gold because i'm like
i'm seeing everyone like the day before
i'm researching presumably just like
next doctor who georgina campbell i'm
like whoa okay
i had to ask um but before i let you go
is there anything you want to tell your
fans like what's the reason
they should give wildcat a shot like
what should we look forward to why
should we watch it
um i think people should watch wildcats
i think hopefully it's really
entertaining it's a really exciting film
and it's a very you know it's very
empowering for like a woman
and it's action and she really overcomes
all the odds and
yeah i just think it's really
entertaining yes and i could
totally support that statement she's
made everyone check it out it's coming
out in select theaters
this friday and releases digital and on
demand
april 27th that is wildcat you don't
want to miss it you get to see georgina
campbell absolutely crush it here
georgina thank you so much for joining
me today and i hope to talk to you in
the future
thank you so much it was lovely to meet
you thank you
bye